und da sind wir wieder zurück bei 8:15
Uhr schön dass Sie bei uns sind ja vor
einigen Tagen saß meine Kollegin Elke
buderas von der Welt hier bei viertel
nach acht und sie hat dramatische
Recherchen zu impfen Nebenwirkungen der
corona-impfung mitgebracht sie sagte
auch dass da ist nur die Spitze das
Eisbergs es wird noch sehr viel mehr
kommen hier ist es jetzt Anwalt Tobias
Ulbricht und er sagt da kommt allerdings
eine riesige Welle auf uns zu welche
Themen welche Schäden welche Probleme
haben Menschen die davon ausgehen dass
sie einen Impfschaden haben und was kann
jetzt getan werden das ist jetzt sein
Thema
wir liegen alle diejenigen am Herzen die
in Folge mit der Impfung gesundheitliche
Schäden erlitten haben und das sind
erstaunlich viele wir haben in den
letzten Zeit 5000
Erstberatungen kostenlos durchgeführt
und es sind viele Erstberatungen die
eigentlich die Hilflosigkeit zum
Ausdruck bringen nämlich dass sie nicht
die richtigen Ärzte finden dass sie sich
im Stich gelassen fühlen ähm dass sie
sich mit den ganzen behördlichen
Informationen nicht zu Recht finden das
möglicherweise auch die Anträge die
gestellt worden sind besser nicht hätten
gestellt werden sollen und niemand klärt
die Geschädigten tatsächlich auch
deshalb möchte ich gerne mit ein paar
Mythen heute aufräumen nämlich das erste
der Geschädigte müsse doch den ähm die
kausalitätsnachweis führen zwischen
Impfung und Schaden wir haben im
Arzneimittelrecht in Folge eben des
contergans Skandals hinein geschrieben
bekommen insgesetz dass dann wenn eine
geringe Wahrscheinlichkeit zwischen
Impfung und Schaden dargelegt worden ist
dann entsprechend von Gesetzeswegen
vermutet wird dass die gesundheitlichen
Schäden auf der Impfung beruhen das
heißt der Hersteller muss darlegen und
beweisen dass seinen wachsen kein
Beitrag zum Schaden geleistet haben kann
das heißt die Aufgabe des Herstellers
ist es dann
ersatzkausalitäten zu finden das ist
auch das was dann in den gerichtlichen
Verfahren passiert und er hat zwei
weitere Einwendungen und die sind
Gegenstand der medialen
Berichterstattung mehr als eigentlich
das was im Gerichtssaal stattfindet
nämlich der schicksalhafte Einzelfall
soll hinter den überragenden Nutzen der
Impfungen zurücktreten und diesbezüglich
haben wir einen sehr schwieriges Medien
Setting erlebt dass immer von uns
einzelne Mandanten gezeigt worden sind
im öffentlichen Fernsehen und dann kam
immer ein Experte der das hohe Loblied
auf die im gesungen hat so dass der
schicksalhafte Einzelfall gegen eine
computermodellierung gestellt worden ist
und diese computermodellierung die dort
stattgefunden hat die ist auch die
Grundlage dafür dass eine Million Tote
in Deutschland gerettet worden sein
sollen jeder erinnert sich vielleicht
noch in welcher Reihenfolge das hier in
Deutschland stattgefunden hat das erste
was erst passiert war ist nämlich dass
es gegen die Infektion und gegen die
Übertragung helfen sollte deshalb haben
wir ja alle 2G und 3G erlebt und stellte
sich heraus nein es hilft nicht gegen
die Infektion es hilft auch nicht gegen
die Übertragung dann sollte es gegen
schwere Verläufe helfen nein ist halt
auch nicht gegen schwere Verläufe es
soll nur noch das Immunsystem stärken
ist der Stand und dann auf einmal soll
es viele Millionen Tote gerettet haben
kann das stößt nachher wieder auf die
empirische Realität die da vom
entsprechenden Statistischen Bundesamt
niedergelegt ist wir hätten also 2020
eine Übersterblichkeit haben müssen von
über einer Millionen um anschließend die
Millionen retten zu können hatten wir
sie nein 2020 gab es keine
Übersterblichkeit sie stieg 2021 und war
2022 entsprechend höher ist einmal
runter von den großen Zahlen auf die
Einzelfälle die Sie gerade angesprochen
haben mit welchen Impfschäden kommen
Menschen zu ihnen was beobachten Sie da
also wir haben verschiedenste
Impfschäden das ist ein von der
Statistik her ziemlich ähnlich die
führen wir übrigens auch wie das eben
bei der EMA und beim Pie auch
stattfindet wir haben neurologische
Schäden als einen der großen Bigpoints
also das auf einmal Muskulatur nicht
mehr angesprochen wird dass es partielle
Lähmungserscheinungen gibt bis hin eben
zur Querschnittslähmung wir haben
Autoimmunerkrankung auch in
verschiedenster Formen mit
hyperinformationseffekten im ganzen
Körper wir haben die
Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen mit
Myokarditis pericarditis was ja bekannt
ist aber auch eben endothelitis
Vaskulitis in schwersten Form und die
ganzen thrombosefälle mit entsprechenden
Blatt Cloud Bildung vielleicht haben
genau
das Video von der Celine gesehen ja der
haben Sie also diese Blatt Klotz überall
aus den Adern als 17-Jährige rausgezogen
die kriegt jeden Tag Blut Fischen ja und
die steht jeden Tag zwischen Leben und
Tot
Menschen die zu Ihnen kommen haben sie
können sie irgendwie eine Altersgruppe
ausmachen ich war zunächst schockiert
dass wir so viele Frauen haben und zwar
Frauen im Alter zwischen 30 und 55
Jahren und das bei uns die Hauptgruppe
ausmacht fast 75 Prozent und dann kam
sehr viel später eben die Übermittlung
des periodical safety Update Reports ist
der erste den biontech eingereicht hatte
im Juni 2021 und siehe da bei den Stand
auch im Report 75% Frauenanteil also
eine dreifach höhere Wahrscheinlichkeit
dass Frauen eben entsprechende Schäden
erleiden als Männer jetzt haben sie
gerade auch gesagt über den Nachweis
gesprochen wie schwierig das ganze ist
was macht Sie so sicher dass die
Menschen die zu Ihnen kommen an einem
Impfschaden leiden und nicht etwa unter
gesundheitlichen Problemen die auch so
aufgetreten werden müssen von der
Begrifflichkeit nur ein bisschen
aufpassen ja der Impfschaden ist das was
ein Paragraph
gegen niedergelegt ist also schwerer
schwere über normalen Nebenwirkungen
hinausgehen auf Dauer eingelegte Schäden
die auch den Gegenstand der Prüfung im
Rahmen von Paragraph 60 IfSG das sind
also diese
versorgungsamtsanträge bilden auch
übrigens einer der Gründe dafür warum so
viele dort abgelehnt werden ich brauche
nämlich dort ein Impfschaden wir
sprechen hier um über gesundheitliche
Schäden also alle gesundheitlichen
Folgen die im Folge eben der Impfung
entstanden sind und das sind nicht nur
im Schäden jetzt muss ich trotzdem noch
mal die Frage auch verzeihen Sie mir
welche Begriffe nicht komplett drauf
habe was macht sie sicher bei den
Menschen die zu Ihnen kommen dass die
gesundheitlichen Probleme aus der
Impfung resultieren das hatte ich
eingangs versucht zu erläutern das war
nämlich die Märchenstunde knackig also
der Gegner muss beweisen dass sein
wachsen keinen Beitrag zu dem
gesundheitlichen Schaden geleistet haben
kann es wird vom Gesetz deswegen
fingiert dass der gesundheitliche
Schaden auf der Impfung beruht so und
erst wenn ersatzkausalitäten gefunden
sind also es kann auch an dem liegen es
kann auch angeben liegen Beweis
Sachverständigengutachten dann
der Richter sich an ob diese
ersatzkausalität dann diese gesetzliche
beweisvermutung entkräftet dennoch macht
vielen Menschen muss man auch wirklich
sagen und man muss der Busen sagen
Medien aller Art berichten derzeit über
die steigende Zahl von Impfschäden sehen
Sie jetzt all das was beschlossen wurde
die einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht
beispielsweise die impfpflichte immer
noch bei der Bundeswehr gilt mit anderen
Augen also ich zum Glück niemand aus
seinem ganzen Bekanntenkreis der an
dieser Impfung krank geworden ist oder
darunter leidet zum Glück nicht aber
diese Sachverhalte müssen muss die
Politik dann nicht lösen sondern müssen
dann die Gerichte erklären und wenn das
tatsächlich so ist dass da so viele
Menschen erkrankt sind dann weiß ich im
Moment nicht
wie diese Prozesse dann geführt werden
oder gibt es da Sammelklagen oder jede
einzelne klagen und ich weiß auch die
mit der Beweis Umkehr Last ob wer was
beweisen muss ich meine nur dass sie
dort unsere Impfung doch insgesamt viel
gewonnen haben dass wir eigentlich
dankbar sein können dass wir geimpft
worden sind es wäre ja wahrscheinlich
viel schlimmer gewesen wenn wir kein
Impfstoff gehabt hätten und die
Impfkommission die Experten die alle
dazu geraten haben zu impfen ich bin
natürlich auch geimpft
übrigens sie hören viel gewonnen durch
die Impfung was löst das bei Ihnen aus
da kann man eben nur sagen eine die
Wiederholung einer Lüge wird irgendwann
als Wahrheit begriffen und genau das ist
das was wir eben auch die ganze Zeit
wahrnehmen ja also wir haben tatsächlich
empirisch betrachtet keinerlei Nutzen
sondern nur Schaden und die die
tatsächlich Aufsätze wir haben 1.300
wissenschaftliche Aufsätze zu Bereich
gesammelt die geben eigentlich auch an
Aufschluss darüber dass im Sinne eben
das Arzneimittelrechts es sich um
bedenklicher Arzneimittel handeln könnte
es ist dabei nicht erforderlich dass sie
es tatsächlich sind bedenklich sind sie
schon wenn aus der Wissenschaft
ersichtlich erhebliche Gefahren eben mit
dem Stoff verbunden sind und die
wissenschaftlichen Gutachten die
schreien es gerade zu heraus und es ist
eigentlich eine Schande dass wir keine
Institution haben die sich in
vernünftiger Art und Weise eben dieser
wissenschaftlichen Literatur gewidmet
hat aber mein Eindruck ist dass sie da
übertreiben ehrlich gesagt ich bin
dreimal geimpft um das klar zu sagen und
ich fühle mich wohl man musste ja damals
richtig kämpfen um Termin überhaupt ich
war sehr erleichtert als der Impfstoff
drin war möchte ich hier ganz klar sagen
deswegen wenn Sie jetzt von so großen
riesigen sprechen ich will nicht
absprechen das ist diese Fälle gibt und
man sollte diese Fälle auch ernst nehmen
dass Menschen die sagen ich habe glaube
ich habe dadurch irgendwie ein Schaden
erlitten dass man dann tut das
Verschwörungstheoretiker die waren so
lange auf der youtube-akademie und was
man den alles dann an Kopf wirft das
sollte nicht sein ist ja auch so dass
der eben in die Haftung gegangen ist
gesagt hat wir machen schnell Zulassung
für diese Impfstoffe und der Staat also
die Steuerzahler haftet am Ende und
nicht die Unternehmen die diese Stoffe
entwickelt haben wenn man das so macht
muss man sagen dann muss man eben auch
genau Auswerten welche Folgen hat denn
das da kommen jetzt natürlich sie ins
Spiel ist auch völlig in Ordnung aber
also wir haben ganz viele wir haben ganz
viele geschädigt die genauso gesprochen
haben bevor sie dann ihren Schaden
erlitten haben die haben ein Jahr und 3
Monate oder noch länger nichts und von
einem Tag auf dem anderen ist es
tatsächlich vorbei also ich war
irgendwann vom Stuhl gesagt nein das ich
weiß es doch nicht was was sie
persönlich bei sich im Körper haben
jedenfalls wir haben jetzt
[Gelächter]
wissen wir ja aufgrund dessen was sie
dänischen Wissenschaftler da gefragt
haben ja das eben die der Stoff der
produziert werden sollte vertraglich
ursprünglich mal über 70% Integrität
haben sollte es wurde dann herabgesetzt
auf 50%, dann hatten war ich ja selber
eben anwesend bei der Beweisaufnahme vor
dem Bundesverwaltungsgericht im Juli des
letzten Jahres haben wir Herrn Dr Wagner
von dem PI der es dir für die
chargenprüfung zuständig gefragt und er
hat gesagt was machen Sie denn in der
chargenprüfung ja 31 der 35 Tests macht
der Hersteller selbst wir machen vier
wir machen eine Sichtprüfung wir halten
einmal gegen der helle Wand wir halten
einmal gegen eine dunkle Wand dann
machen wir im gel-verfahren testen wir
die Länge eben der RNA und die darf zu
kurz sein die darf aber nicht zu lang
sein haben wir gefragt was macht denn
eine zu kurze RNA das Wissen er nicht
das interessiere ihn auch nicht weil ja
die immer gesagt hat zu kurz dürfte sie
sein aber zu lange eben nicht aber wenn
sie mal sehen unter unter Impfstoff in
Deutschland der war doch gut und wenn
wir die Vergleich mit dem chinesischen
Impfstoff der nichts gebracht hat der
Gang dann müssen wir eigentlich davon
ausgehen dass das doch eine gute Sache
gewesen ist ja Busen die Sache ist ja
das wissen eigentlich nicht mehr und ich
bin der Meinung wie sie aber trotzdem
ist das ja fast nicht mehr die Mehrheit
ist Meinung sondern die Meinung wird ja
geprägt von von Herrn Ulbrich und vielen
vielen anderen auch Gutachten wieder im
Netz sind es gibt eins über Pfizer zum
Beispiel was unter Verschluss bleiben
sollte aber dann auf Basis von über
300.000 Seiten veröffentlicht worden ist
wo ähnliche
Nachweise erbracht werden also deswegen
muss Politik doch eigentlich dann
Interesse haben Aufklärung zu leisten
dann kann ich sagen wir haben alles
gemacht und alles gut mir geht's gut ihm
geht's gut aber vielen anderen geht's
vielleicht nicht so gut also man muss
doch aufklären denn sonst wissen wir gar
nicht mehr tatsächlich auf Basis der mal
auch gerne wissenschaftlichen
Erkenntnisse was da was da jetzt ist und
auch Politik müsste sagen wir versuchen
mal zu klären wie jetzt wirklich die
Lage ist nachdem wir 60 80 Millionen
Menschen empfohlen haben sich
entsprechend impfen zu lassen die
Politik dazu wenig in der Verantwortung
also diese Sache Aufklärung ist ganz
klar Sache der gerichtete raus
halten
gegründet wird dass man viele
Versäumnisse und vieler in der
corona-zeit mal aufklärt warum soll die
Politik darf in die Finger lassen es
wird ja auch es wird dann
Untersuchungsausschuss ist eingeleitet
worden Werner viele Dinge jetzt
eingeleitet die zu Aufklärung führen
aber wenn solche Dinge die müssen
aber er gibt noch nicht aber den ähm
okay wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
vielen vielen Dank
Bild kämpft für Sie